welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the netflix daredevil universe
is now crossing over with the mcu with
these series finally joining the disney
plus platform after charlie cox's mcu
debut as matt murdock daredevil and
spider-man no way home and vincent
d'onofrio's role as wilson fisk kingpin
and hawkeye actually check out the
latest disney plus promo who wants
something
there's history here something personal
embrace the chaos
saved the best for last huh
force of habit i'm just getting started
huh no iron fist that's it i'm
unsubscribing said no one these titles
rejoining the marvel family on disney
plus is undeniably great news for the
fans who watched all these hours of
content and for viewers who haven't yet
seen them you're in for a world of pain
and pleasure but the big question with
these series has been how will marvel
reconcile their previously separate
continuities with the history of the mcu
are these defenders all exactly the
characters their latest seasons left
them as on netflix well finally we got
an answer from charlie cox who at the
middle east film in comic con in abu
dhabi spoke extensively about where matt
murdock was left at the end of daredevil
season three you really wanted that
season four do you think where you
wanted the character to go then is the
place you want the character to go now
like how was that time off how did you
make you understand the material
differently i don't think it makes sense
to pick up where we left off in keeping
with a lot of things in the mcu right
now where there's this alternate reality
kind of thing going on you know there's
been a few years have passed and now
i don't know
it's daredevil but
maybe there's it's not quite it's
there's some it's just it's reimagined
it's slightly different it's it you know
what i text one of my friends when i
found out this is all happening it's
born again
so uh you know the sky's the limit let's
see so it's confirmed the matt murdock
and spider-man no way home and in future
mcu titles like echo or even his solo
series on disney plus is not the same
exact matt murdock as we saw at the end
of daredevil season 3 but rather an
alternate reality variant in the mcu
separate from the daredevil in the
netflix series he and vincent d'onofrio
wilson fisk are alternate versions of
themselves who always existed in the
background of the mcu reality
intertwining with the histories of the
avengers the battle of new york even
earlier this is a distinctly different
timeline than the history we saw them go
through in the netflix shows despite
that history sometimes making reference
to the events of the mcu like the battle
of new york deleted scenes from hawkeye
showed eleanor bishop meeting with fisk
in 2012 after derek's death in the
battle of new york as well as fisk being
confirmed as uncle to maya lopez which
would have made him a crime boss as
early as 2007.
i know you've been dealing with my
husband
but as i'm sure you've heard
he's gone
so now you're dealing with me
i recognize that you like to get down to
business
i respect that i'd like to offer my
condolences to you and your daughter
but your husband made a mess of things
and now you're going to clean it up
i'm not going to do this forever you
don't have to
you do it until it's done
the bad news is that your father had to
work a little and couldn't pick you up
good news
that means that i can take you to have
some ice cream
ice cream
so by bringing back charlie cox and
vincent d'onofrio it looks as though
marvel is applying the same rule of
sometimes the same actor plays variants
across universes the rule that sony used
for j.k simmons is j jonah jameson and
michael keaton is adrian toomes and what
marvel seems to also be doing with
patrick stewart as professor x with the
one and multiverse of madness probably
not the same exact guy as the one from
the fox x-men films charlie cox uses
terms like reimagined born again an
homage to but says the sky's the limit
all to suggest that this new take on the
character won't be held down by any of
the plot threats that came before but
these characters also seem to be
benefiting from the best parts of their
character development their
relationships and their heroic and
villainous attributes as were
established on those netflix shows so
it's still gonna be very very important
to watch or re-watch those seasons of
daredevil to know where this guy came
from and to that end we here at new
rockstars plan to break down daredevil
season one a video coming to the channel
in the next couple weeks keep an eye out
for it now to be honest sometimes i stay
up super late finishing these videos and
i just want to sleep in but all the
electric lights in our lives just make
it hard to get the bedroom totally dark
well that is where the blue blocks
remedy sleep mask comes in handy we knew
blue blocks from their blue light
blocking glasses but their sleep mask
goes farther and blocks out 100 of light
for better sleep it's super soft and it
has these adjustable eye cups and an
adjustable strap for the perfect fit it
works for people who sleep on their
belly on their side on their back or for
those of us who go to our secret rooms
inside of our homes and like just string
up with all of our leather apparatuses
like it's made from the super breathable
material i'm opening my eyes does that
freak you out christian gray
i mean it's great for improving sleep
for meditation for napping for travel i
love using it when i want to sleep in or
like try to grab a nap during the day
try to sleep on a plane blue box also
ships worldwide and has other great
products like the red light therapy
devices so go to blueblocks.com new
rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save twenty percent that's
blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20 but
just to quickly recap daredevil on
netflix consisted of three 13-episode
seasons one eight-episode crossover
series the defenders and then from that
several interconnected storylines
including three seasons of jessica jones
two seasons of the punisher two seasons
of luke cage and two seasons of iron
fist a brief summary of daredevil's
storyline in season one he begins as the
man in black vigilante who ends up
coming into conflict with wilson fisk as
well as with nobu a warrior from the
hand by the end of the first season he
becomes the devil of hell's kitchen and
daredevil and fisk ends up behind bars
in season two matt's old flame elektra
returns and nelson and murdoch take on
the case of murderous vigilante frank
castle the castle blows his own case and
in prison helps fisk eliminate enemies
meanwhile nobu returns representing the
hand's rising threat in new york and in
a final fight elektra gives her life to
save matt but she doesn't stay dead for
long because in defenders murdoch teams
up with jessica jones luke cage and
danny rand to fight the hand in new york
in the hand uses their resurrected
assassin elektra aka black sky their
goal is to unearth a giant dragon
skeleton from beneath the city and
defenders ends with matt and elektra
seeming to die in each other's arms
under a collapsing building but murdock
returns at daredevil season 3 where fisk
now under house arrest uses ben point
dexter aka bullseye to pose his
daredevil and that season ends with this
breaking his back and while murdoch
nearly beats fist to death he ultimately
just gets him re-arrested using leverage
against vanessa so what from all of this
will carry over into the mcu version of
daredevil clearly matt murdock is a
well-established defense attorney in new
york city who works federal cases
considering peter parker was being
prosecuted by the federal department of
damage control and matt murdock already
has his daredevil agile reflexes this
means he already suffered the chemical
accident as a kid that left him blind
and perhaps he also worked with a
version of stick maybe scott glenn's
version who taught him how to use his
other senses and enhance his reflexes
and then as a lawyer he has also already
established the firm of nelson and
murdoch with foggy nelson most likely in
which case it's gonna be a bit weird to
see someone else other than eldon hinson
play that character alongside charlie
cox so hopefully they bring him back too
it's just not yet clear if this matt
murdock has officially become the devil
of hell's kitchen or if he has crossed
paths with wilson fisk i'm going to
assume no or they're in their early
throws of their conflict because as soon
as these two heavyweights become aware
of each other it's not long before one
of them ends up incarcerated or severely
incapacitated by late 2024 when hawkeye
and no way home take place concurrently
as rogers the musical is running in new
york in both titles both men are active
and mostly unbruised but again this is
an alternate reality so now the mcu can
really pick and choose which of the
netflix plot threads to make part of the
mcu daredevil's backstory maybe he
already knows frank castle and jessica
jones and luke cage or maybe he hasn't
met them yet maybe he hasn't yet battled
with the hand or even knows what the
hand is maybe he's tried to hit kingpin
before but kingpin walked away unscathed
so that's why i think it's so important
to re-watch these series when they drop
on disney plus because anything and
everything we liked about them could
come back as part of the canonical
backstory for daredevil for kingpin for
anyone else who's now in the mcu
actually keep an eye out for this
sunday's episode of big question where
they're gonna look at all of the netflix
marvel titles to see which titles are
most likely to cross over into the mcu
as we look ahead you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you